à la renaissance on mène la grande vie
c'est un siècle où on fait boire sa
richesse les demeures deviennent
beaucoup plus une chose on construit des
choses qui ne sont pas forcément
d'ailleurs habité mais pour le plaisir
ce bâtiment il a été construit par goût
de luxe à l'époque de françois 1er de la
forteresse qui existait au début on a
essayé de transformer pour en faire une
demeure de plaisance sur les fenêtres
qui sont sur la toiture on reconnaît
bien là la salamandre de françois 1er et
l'hermine de claude de france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce qui a été assez réussie dans ce
château c'est justement le mélange des
styles pour arriver à faire un bâtiment
qui est assez harmonieux finalement
puisqu'on a quand même quatre époques
qui sont mélangés entre la tour du 15e
siècle et notamment l'extrême droite
vous avez le xviiie siècle qui est
beaucoup moins orné beaucoup moins
sculpter les choses qu'on faisait à la
renaissance
on a si vous voulez un élément
renaissance qui est le très grand
bâtiment qui se trouve au milieu avec
les fenêtres sur le toit mais l'ensemble
du château n'est pas spécialement
renaissance
parrot naissance c'est presque là but si
vous voulez de la dorure de la
décoration des tableaux de maîtres alors
qu'au 15e on n'était pas du tout dans ce
genre de style vous avez ici un très
beau cabinet de la renaissance italienne
il est du milieu du xviie siècle on
appelait ça à l'époque un cabinet à
secret d'où le mot maintenant secrétaire
[Musique]
les miroirs un servait à dissimuler les
compartiments secrets
[Musique]
les pièces de réception le camp salon et
la salle à manger ont été installés au
deuxième étage
alors qu'en général dans les châteaux
d'apparat c'est plutôt au premier étage
qu'on faisait de ce genre d'installation
là on s'explique pas d'ailleurs très
bien le fait que ça a été installée au
deuxième mais bon ici c'est comme ça
[Musique]